una nacionaria condenada dos años de
libertad condicional así lo dispuso un
tribunal alemán que castigó a ingare de
97 años por ser cómplice en alrededor de
11.000 asesinatos durante el nazismo
cuando era secretaria en el campo de
concentración de stuthoff en el norte de
Polonia
solo era una secretaria se dice
fácilmente
el de una secretaria en ese momento en
la burocracia de
de un camponner trabajó como taquígrafa
y mecanógrafa entre junio de 1943 y
abril de 1945 cuando tenía solo 18 años
la fiscalía señaló que ella colaboró al
funcionamiento del campo de
concentración donde 65,000 personas
murieron de hambre o en cámara de gas y
albergaba a prisioneros de guerra y
judíos capturados
después de escuchar las pruebas el
tribunal decidió que a través de su
trabajo como Taki mecanógrafa apoyó
conscientemente y voluntariamente la
muerte cruel de 10.500 prisioneros a
través de la gasificación de condiciones
inhumanas en el campo
los abogados Defensores de fogner que
fue juzgada bajo la ley de menores por
su edad durante el nazismo pidieron la
absolución de la acusada pero no
tuvieron éxito y evitaron hablar sobre
la sentencia
esa es una pregunta que nunca
responderemos son libres de observar al
acusado durante el juicio pero no
haremos ningún comentario al respecto
había elementos de lo sucedido en el
final de un juicio que duró 40 días y
que se suma a la lista de condenas de
Cómplices administrativos que inició en